simple things to do if you want to keep your man happy in your relationship
No 1. give intimacy
unless you wanna just be a roommate
make sure you satisfy his needs
No. 2. make sure you're cooking for him
generations these days do not see the importance of cooking for their man
men do not want a sandwich
cook them dinner
No. 3 clean
stop complaining and keep your home tidy
let your man be the man and take care of him
okay gender roles are okay sometimes you clean the house
he takes out the garbage and mows the lawn
No. four stop nagging
you're not his mother stop acting like it
if he doesn't wanna do something
get over it and move on
No. 5 Tespect and appreciate him
you do this and it'll make him work 10 times harder for you and the family
men are natural born providers
And respect to men is like love to women
All of the top tier women know this
and that is why their men never cheat and they stay happy